COMMENCEZ ICI
ALLEZ N'IMPORTE OÙ
J'étudie au British Council,
car j'aime l’anglais.
J'aime étudier au British Council,
car les professeurs sont sympas.
J'aime apprendre au British Council,
car j'aime passer du temps
avec ceux qui deviennent mes amis.
On développe
notre confiance en soi
à l'aide
de nos professeurs experts.
Ça m’aide à améliorer mes compétences,
tels que ma présentation
et mon accent.
Je peux m'exprimer librement,
partager mes expériences
et penser autrement.
On nous apprend les fondamentaux
et surtout à parler en anglais.
Les cours sont agréables,
C’est comme si j’étais en Angleterre.
Leurs activités sont amusantes
pour tout âge.
Ça nous aidera pour notre avenir.
Et ça me rend très heureux.
OÙ IREZ-VOUS?
Avec vos compétences en anglais,
je veux visiter Londres
et rencontrer la Reine.
Je veux étudier au Royaume-Uni,
l'anglais est très important
pour réaliser mon rêve.
Je veux réduire la pollution,
le braconnage et sauver l'humanité.
Je veux être pilote d'avion
grâce à l'anglais.
Écrire des histoires
et communiquer.
Pouvoir parler anglais
avec mes cousins et ma famille.
Je veux aller au Royaume-Uni.
Je veux visiter des observatoires.
Je veux travailler à la NASA.
Voyager et rencontrer
des gens de toutes cultures.
Comme disait Cervantès:
«Tout est possible.»
L'anglais est la langue
qui lie les pays ensemble.
Il n'y a pas mieux
que le British Council
pour apprendre l’anglais.
Et vous vous ferez de très bons amis.
Le British Council m'aide
à améliorer mon anglais
et me rapproche de mon rêve!
APPRENEZ AVEC NOUS
L'ANGLAIS NOUS CONNECTE
BRITISH COUNCIL